He is one of the most popular and enduring icons over the American West,
the gentleman bandit,
charmed his way through life,
always keeping one step ahead of the law with this fabled wild banshee,
terrorize the banks and the railway companies during the closing decade of the
19th century.
Then he headed south of the border only to meet his match at the hands of
Bolivian treats.
In this week's biographics graphics,
we delve into the life and the death of butch cassidy.
Leroy Parker was born in beaver use R on April the third,
18,
66.
It was named after his grandfather who helps lead a group of Mormon handcart
refugees thousands of miles across the country to the Utopia that was Utah.
Traveling along the Mormon trail.
They pulled all of their belongings in handcarts with that faith and Brigham
young in the Lord.
They headed into the snow drifts of the continental divide.
Robert Parker senior was a strong man.
That's the harsh winter.
It was too much for him that he was found dead one morning frozen in his blanket
policy forged on and often many trials.
They made it to Utah Pollock,
his widow in 12 year old son Max settled at American fork,
some 30 miles south of Salt Lake City in 18,
65.
They moved to beaver were Max married,
Don Campbell.
The couple would go on to have 13 children together.
Robert known as Bob.
He was the oldest.
Max polica became a successful businessman when Bob was a young child.
His father purchased a ranch 12 miles south of Circleville and to move the
family that they employed,
a number of cowboys including a petty criminal by the name of Mike Cassidy
Cassidy.
He took a shine to young Bob who appeared to idolize these swaggering outlaw.
He told the boy he has a shoot,
a gun ride,
a horse,
rope and brands,
and Russell Castle.
Bob was a good study and by the time he was 16,
he had developed a reputation as a fine,
shortens a competent horseman.
He developed into a solid,
strapping teenager with a pleasant and jovial personality.
There is not a lot known about butches later teen years.
It appears that he took work as a rancher in various locations until 1884.
At one point he gains work as a butcher in rock springs,
Wyoming.
It was at this time that he took the nickname.
Butch cassidy was a amash do you?
His childhood hero,
Mike Cassidy Cassidy's first run in with the law occurred around 1880.
He wanted to buy some food and some clothes,
but found the shop to be closed on detail.
Z simply broke in and took a pair of jeans as well as a pipe.
However,
he also left an Iou note indicating that he would return to settle his account
later.
The shopkeeper,
though he was not impressed and he had butcher arrested.
The case ended up before the courts were.
Jury acquitted him
in
1999.
A 23 year olds.
Butch cassidy turns up in telluride,
Colorado,
located in the San Juan Mountains.
Telluride was a wild mining town full of gold.
Hungry prospect is the place was filled with saloons,
gambling houses and brothels.
Sitting right smack in the middle of town was the San Miguel Valley Bank.
Cassidy,
he teamed up with a fellow drift,
a by the name of Matt Warner,
and the two were joined investors in a race horse named betty.
The money for that investment came through cattle rustling.
They then decided to set their sights a little higher determining to rob the
local bank.
It is believed that they robbed the stage in Denver prior to the bank heist.
They then made a show of spending money liberally around telluride in order to
show that they were not desperate men on the morning of June,
the 24th,
18,
89 cassidy,
warner and two accomplices,
one who is believed to have been Harry longer bob best known as the Sundance
kid,
hitch the horses outside of the livery store in telluride and then headed for a
saloon not far from the San Miguel Valley Bank just prior to noon.
They noticed one of the tellers exit the bank,
leaving just one man on duty to have the Alamo's cabs,
God outside,
while the other two went to the bank,
and amazingly none of the robbers bothered to wear a mask or otherwise conceal
his identity.
History also does not reveal the role that each individual plate.
We do know though that one of the men who went into the bank approach the loan
tatler and told him that he wanted to cash a check when the man began to inspect
the track has had,
was grabbed and shoved into the desk at this point,
so the two outside came in and for began ransacking the bank in such a money,
they go away with more than $20,000 on the way out of town.
Cassidy and one over recognize by two men still.
They managed to get away hiding out in a remote area of southeastern Utah,
known as robber's roost.
This would become a favorite place of escape.
The cassidy and his gang,
who builds cabins there and catch this stone and cattle horses and weaponry in
this area.
Cassidy used some of the profits from that bank job to buy a ranch near Dubois,
Wyoming.
In 1894,
he began a relationship with a teenage girl by the name of Anne Bassett,
who was the daughter of a wealthy cattle rancher for four years after the San
Miguel Valley bank robbery.
Butch managed to live the life of a law abiding citizen.
However,
shortly after becoming involved with and he was arrested for horse stealing,
his trial took place in Monza,
Wyoming.
Guns resulted in his conviction and sentence to two years imprisonment at the
Wyoming state penitentiary and Laramie.
Cassidy proved to be a model prisoner.
He applied to the Wyoming governor for a Audi release.
This was agreed on the condition that he would stay out of trouble in the
future.
Butch,
he agreed,
but he had no intention of following through on that promise.
Immediately upon his release on January the 19th,
18,
96,
he rejoined his gang.
That's an area of their robin's roost hideaway,
known as the hole in the wall.
It was following butches release from Wyoming state penitentiary that he and his
wild bunch gang began their crime spree and honest.
The gang was in,
launched more than 30 members with a core of such notables as the Sun Dawns Kid,
kid curry,
and I was a lay on the afternoon of August the 13th,
18,
96,
three men in Montpellier,
Idaho.
They dismounted in front of the bank and then to have them pulled that bandannas
over their faces,
the bend quickly pulled out that revolvers and the two wearing bandanas.
How did the men into the bank inside were a number of customers and bank
employees.
Everyone except for one of the cashiers was ordered to line up against the wall.
One of the rabbids who is believed to have been cassidy kept his gun trained on
the terrifying customers while another filter bags with cash,
gold and silver that before leaving with that $7,000,
but cassidy or did the people to wait for 10 minutes before raising the alarm.
The Robo who had remained downside bald makes was the only one who did not cover
his face.
He was recognized by the town residents and ended up being one of only three
people.
It was captured and convicted of the crime.
Cassidy was well known in Utah,
runs as a result,
as a general rule of not committing crimes in that state.
However,
in April of 18,
97 be made an exception to that rule.
His target was the payroll of the Pleasant Valley Coal Company and cost gate.
This was the largest coal mine in Carbon County,
Utah.
Furthermore,
it was ideally located between the gangs favorite high downs of robbers roost
and Brown's hole.
The company knew that that payroll was an enticing prize for bandits,
and so they tried to prevent heists by keeping irregular paydays.
The payroll came in on a train that was heavily guarded.
Butch decided there's going off against the train,
was too risky,
and so he did tell him and take the money directly from the payment stuff in
order to do so high for the gang,
would need to know when the payroll was going to arrive.
On April the 17th cassidy road into the town of castle gate and went to one of
the saloons were inquired if there was any work going for a run hand.
He was told that the might be if he was patient enough with his excuse for
hanging around now established.
He made his way to the train depot.
He watched the goings on as the train came and wins,
and then returned to the saloon for the next week.
He repeated this process,
observing every train that came into town on April the 22nd cassidy's patients.
It was finally rewarded a whistle from the mine,
announced that it was payday.
When the train arrived,
butch watched from a distance is the paymaster fit.
Coffins.
Aaron's,
a couple of aides,
carried money bags from the train to his office.
The bags were heavy.
You containing more than $7,000 in gold and I have a $100 in Silva,
so the men were going slowly then just as a ready decline.
The stands for the paymasters office.
Calvin's a was approached from behind and a revolver was poked into its rips.
Butch informs him that he was about to relieve him and his pals of their load.
Adding the did hate to have to shoot any of them.
Competency was stunned that such a brazen attack would be attempted in broad
daylight.
There were plenty of miners arounds,
but very few of them spoke English or would have been aware of what was going
on.
Gang member Elza lay and the from the shadows and helps butch take possession of
the moneybags coffins that and his helpers,
left them to it,
seeking protection in the nearby Howard West.
All the paymaster then began yelling out that had been robbed.
Cassidy and lay attempted to mount their horses well stealing the money and that
saddlebags if a butcher,
his horse got spooked and took off,
leaving him standing in the middle of the street with a bag of gold in his hand,
lay managed to track the horse down and bring it back to the two,
and they made away with over $7,000 in gold.
They left the bag of silver just lying in the street.
Payments to compensate and out sprang into action.
He ran for the Telegraph office,
instructed the to send an urgent message to the authorities in price,
which was some 10 miles away.
However,
the clerk told him the lines had been cut thinking fast.
He made for the train and told the driver to hightail it to price.
As the train chugged along,
it went right past the fleeing Roberts.
It took several hours before the sheriff.
It price could get a posse organized.
In addition to having this headstart,
butch was also very familiar with the countryside and was easily able to evade
as as local ranches.
We're also happy to provide his gang with fresh horses,
having no loyalty to the big mining companies or indeed the banks constantly in
Lei.
They made it a bag so that base had robber's roost where they lay low with the
other gang members.
The officials in Utah were well aware of where the robbers were,
but showed no enthusiasm for going after them.
As a result of the local papers began to accuse the lawman of cowardice for
three months,
butch and his men spend their time drinking,
gambling and horse riding.
Then when the boredom was too much,
they decided to go out and start spending that takings.
They ranged around buying fine clothes,
getting hack accounts,
and spending up launch in the saloons and the brothels.
By the end of June 19,
97,
it was time to get back to the business of robbery.
The Guy who said that science on the town of Belle fourche,
north of black hills.
On June the 28th,
Butch send gang member Tahmo day to scout out the town.
The plan was to rob the bank once a day had gotten back,
however the day managed to get himself drunk and didn't return to camp until it
was 40.
Relate an angry butch had to delay the heist for 24 hours.
The next day,
Butch selected the Sun Don skid along with George Curry.
Walter put me and Tomo Day to do the job.
That's the Butte county bank.
The three men followed the usual procedure.
Drawing their revolvers is enforcing the customers to stand along the wall with
their hands in the APP.
However possible.
I saw this through the window and they raised the alarm.
Chaos erupts it on the streets.
There's people rush to get off the street while others went for that.
Guns,
the bandits inside,
they quickly realized that they had been found out.
They rushed out,
firing their guns in the air and attempting to get away a couple of towns.
People returned fire from behind.
Cover good.
Carrie was unable to get to his horse,
so trying to mountain mule only to discover that it wouldn't move.
As the other two rode out of town,
Tom O'day attempted to steal away into a side street,
but it was caught and held overnight and the local bank vaults before being
transported to the jail and deadwood the very day the robbery had been an
unmitigated disaster.
It had cost the gang a valued member and earns them just $97 leaving behind
$3,000
and the early morning hours of June,
the second 80 slash 99,
the wild bunch pulled off one of the most celebrated crimes to two members of
the gang with redlands and flags down the Union Pacific overlands flyer train
just outside of the Willcox station and Wilcox,
Wyoming.
The driver thought the two men were warning him that the driving rain has washed
out and approaching bridge.
He threw on the brakes and bring the train to a screeching halt,
but what is all of the men had guns drawn.
He realized the truth and began running down the track to want to come and
drains to back off the bandaid can go and jumps onto the train where they
ordered the engineer to pull the train into a nearby trestle on the far side of
the bridge.
Once the train had crossed over,
one of the bandits lit the fuse to stash of dynamite,
which had been placed on the bridge.
The bridge was damaged enough that the second drain would be unable to follow
the train engineer then,
or did the train forward another two miles where the rest of the gang we're
waiting.
The robbers then made their way to the express call.
I need to find out that the god see he wasn't going to open the door,
so they decided to let me say,
but with dynamize,
this Russell,
the god,
to the extent that he couldn't remember the combination to the safe so well,
the robbers blue,
that open as well.
The result was that all the cash went flying everywhere,
still the gang managed to get away with more than $50,000 worth of cash,
gold and jewelry.
The robbery made national headlines and brought the wild bunch to the attention
of the nation's premier crime fighters,
the Pinkerton Detective Agency for the next two years,
the pinkertons doggedly tracked down the gang.
Meanwhile,
the policy was formed to chase down the train robbers.
They caught up with a three bandits.
On June the sixth,
that Castle creek a gun battle ensued in which kid car he shot and killed the
sheriff leading the posse.
The posse members then with drew is the outlaws escaped.
Butch Cassidy was north of the rough and tumble molds,
most of his contemporary outlaws where he was an extremely sociable man who was
a great conversationalist.
We're not engaged in criminal activity.
Hey impressed others with his strong work ethic.
By 18,
99,
he had a thriving ranch in Dubois,
Wyoming,
and it was growing tired of the outlaw life.
In the summer of that year,
he visited the office of Attorney Orlando Powers in Ogden,
Utah.
He explained to the attorney that he had been portrayed as a vicious criminal
when in fact he has never hurt anybody and it only have a role,
but for large corporations,
Bush.
Then jd powers do approach the governor on his behalf seeking an amnesty deal.
The lawyer responded that a deal was extremely unlikely and the best thing that
butch could do was to go back into hiding.
Undeterred.
Butch sought out another attorney.
This time the meeting was arranged with Utah.
Governor Abbott Wells.
Wells was impressed by cassidy and told him this.
As long as there were no outstanding murder warrants for him,
he was sure that amnesty could be arranged.
The second meeting was arranged which butcher attended in full confidence.
He was surprised to learn however that the governor's office had uncovered and
outstanding murder warrants in his name.
Butch protest is that it never killed a man in his life.
He didn't have to.
Though the governor responded,
the charge was enough.
Immense.
Amnesty was simply out of the question
with the failure of his attempt to go straight.
It seems that butch carried out a string of further robberies around the turn of
the century.
Don't have been linked to a train robbery in Tipton,
Wyoming in August of 1900 and the winner mark in Nevada bank heist a month
later,
though there is no concrete evidence that they took part with no prospects to
end is fugitive life in the west,
which began making plans to head south of the border when he proposed the idea
to his gang members.
Seventy two were interested the sundance kid and could carry before the gang
split up for good.
It's five core members out of final rendezvous in Texas.
Also having their fill of liquor,
fine dining and women.
They sat for a group photograph in new suits.
The photo that was taken on that day made its way to the Pinkerton detective
agency and it was used on wanted posters.
Butch and Sundance then split up promising to meet up again in New York City.
This they did with Sundance being accompanied by his longtime girlfriend at a
place.
The trio boarded the ship bound for when our series on February the 20th,
1,901
immediately upon arrival books using the assumed name of Jim Rohn deposit of
$12,000 in a local bank is the first step and putting up a land claim.
They ended up purchasing 17,000 acres of lands and shall Lilo to their
neighbors.
There appeared to be hardworking,
gringos z except for one disturbing facts.
Wherever they went,
they wore that guns.
Butch and Sundance said,
presumed that a move out of the country would bring it in to that pursuit by the
pinkertons,
but they were mistaken.
Robert Pinkerton,
the head of the agency sends a letter to the [inaudible] police chief with
descriptions and photos of the dealer.
The local police identified them as the two ranches who always wore guns around
cello.
They attempted to keep it close surveillance on the man,
so all the pinkertons arrived and apprehended them.
The two animals would spend seven years in Argentina before the law finally
caught up with them for the first five years.
They kept that noses clean.
Blending in with the locals and becoming popular members.
Of the trinity,
low community.
Then for some reason they returned to a life of crime in the spring of 19.
Oh,
six.
They teamed up with another American fugitive and Robin to the bank and Mercedes
getting away with $20,000.
However,
one of the three robbers shot and killed a bank teller.
Once again,
butch and sundance were on the run
on November the sixth.
It was made their way to send the incentive.
Bolivia,
they were put up in the spare room of a local villager.
However,
a local official identified them and notified members of the Bolivian cavalry.
The room were butch and sundance were holed up with surrounded.
There are a number of versions as to how the last moments played out.
The most accepted version is that sun don't sprint it out onto the patio in a
desperate attempt to get some rifles.
These were located by an outside wall.
Lindsay was firing his revolvers into the errors of distraction as he ran.
However,
he was cut down before he made it off.
The patio.
Butch ran out after him and dragged is mortally wounded.
Friends back inside,
sustaining at least one wound in the process.
After pouring masses of lead into the building and hearing one silence from
within the Bolivian troops finally made their way inside.
They found the bodies of the two outlaws lying on the floor.
Sundance had been shot several times in the arms and once in the forehead,
while butch had a bullet hole in the temple,
the soldiers is in fudge that books should put his best friend out of his misery
before turning the gun on himself.
However,
there was never an inquest and the two men were never formally identified.
The most wanted men in America was simply buried in unmarked graves.
So already have you found this video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos just like this every day of the week.
If you look at something else to watch right now,
do you check out our other videos linked to on the screen?
And as always,
thank you for watching.